c'était suite d'un centre jeff une
rotation genou n'a pas suivi et puis
j'ai entendu un craquement il va se
passer quoi maintenant on va se passer
qui leva la grasse matinée les matins
avant d'être opéré c'est grapo c'est
grave
ben oui parce que quand même la saison
est foutue mes principes je m'en sors
bien parce que les ligaments ne sont pas
tant parce que vous pensez qu'un
accident comme ceux du mini ça va
compromettre une carrière non non ça va
pas qu'on vient d'une carrière parce que
la communiste qu'il n'y aura pas de
séquelles si les ligaments étaient
touchés bon peut-être là le ministre
montréal c'est fini en principe non
parce que ça durera un mois et demi à
deux mois à montréal c'est dans trois
mois alors j'ai encore une petite chance
d'y aller voilà aujourd'hui le moral de
michel platini
il est bon on va tout faire pour
remonter bah oui je crois qu'il est
quand même bon je me dis que j'aurais ça
aurait pu être plus grave est peut être
une conduite en sort bien
c'est le premier accident au non je n'ai
pas mal j'ai eu une fracture de la main
une fracture du bras une double entorse
de la cheville mais sept premiers assez
grave au genou quand même les jumeaux
plus important pour le football c'est un
sport dont j'aurais quand même
non ce n'est pas un sport dangereux mais
c'est un sport où quand même il faut
faire attention à soi
le ménisque en moi est ce que ça va
l'empêcher de jouer aussi bien qu'avant
absolument pas
au point de vue
intégrité physique ce sera le même les
bien évident qu un ménisque à la longue
d'ici une trentaine d'années une
quarantaine d'années pour entraîner des
phénomènes arthrosique
et ça c'est à longue échéance dans
l'immédiat la carrière n'est pas
compromise ou pas et beaucoup d autres
célèbres d'ailleurs à part le pen qui
nous arrive au sujet de platine et je
veux dire par là que ça va bien
s'annoncer comme ceux tenus quand même
qu'on a fait un bon résultat là-bas et
j'espérais que le fait que platini ne
joue pas le seul mot perdure perturbera
pas trop le mot face à une équipe
replâtrer et là vous avez plusieurs
bobos oui disons que ben j'ai patiné le
premier puis du pied qui après un coup
d'ongle dans l'oeil et puis été voir un
spécialiste et disons que j'attends
d'eux mêmes pour savoir si je le feu
vert ou pas mais enfin disons qui s'est
entraîné ce matin qu'il y voit bien ce
que j'aime en aucune manière je crois
que les jours on la fin de saison sans
platines il est ainsi lorraine là
ressemble à quoi mais déjà à une équipe
qui lui manquera un pion essentiel
enfin disons que les gars ont travaillé
en oublie même pour pallier cette
absence est un se serrer les coudes et
je crois que c'est ce que les objectifs
sont changés non on essaiera d'aller le
plus loin possible en coupe
et puis je souhaite de tout coeur qu'ils
soient rétablis pour aller en finale
secrètement vous espériez une place au
moins dans les cinq premiers ben oui
mais enfin vous savez pour l'avenir nous
avons un gros match à domicile et cinq à
l'extérieur 10 ans on est je pense pas
qu'on soit en danger pour la descente
mais en espira en espérant malgré
l'absence de michel de d'aller au delà
de la septième place avant l'accident de
platini nancy une place en coupe
d'europe c'était possible encore oui
m'enfin vous savez moi je vois pas si
loin même si intérieurement on peut
devrait plus arriver ça aurait pu aurait
pu peut-être comme on lui fait à
l'immense joie d'en attraper une
ce qui le co aura doublement